[Music]
I don't think I would tell my younger
self anything because that would mess
with the rules of like time travel and I
don't think I'd be able to make the same
choices that ultimately led me to this
present moment
nobody said that yet it's so obvious
it's so obvious leave it alone leave it
alone let her suffer
if I could talk to myself
before I started all this I would have
warned myself as a hard Road you're
going to lose a lot of your friends
you're not going to have a college
experience your day-to-day is going to
be more than a nine to five and you
won't see the impact until much much
later
and I think that if you could tell any
entrepreneur that the road is not easy
and you know when I thought about the
road not being easy I was like it's not
running a mile right like it's
mental games but the mental games are
really tough I think my mental health
has changed my physical health has
changed and things have happened to me
from this story from this experience
that I'm living that I never thought
could so I would tell myself just be
ready of course I would do this again
and again I think I'm an entrepreneur
for life but the road is not an easy one
at all
I would tell myself something to be
effective of you have no idea what's in
store and how amazing this is going to
be buckle up no I uh although I actually
probably would say that
very corny
[Music]
oh my God I don't know I think I would
tell a young Benny
that the thing that you hate most about
yourself is definitely going to be the
thing that has allowed you to support
yourself and and like truly I am like
living my dream ten times over and I
have to remind myself of that all the
time because sometimes I'm like stressed
that like you know a wig doesn't look
right or a video isn't like the way I
wanted it exactly in my head and I just
have to remind myself like you know I
used to be a kid just dancing to like
oops I did it again in my living room
and then I hid that away for a long time
and I finally came out when I was like a
senior in college and so I just feel
like I I feel like I've Done Right by
that kid
we did it
the advice I give my younger self is uh
take my risk I think every every good
decision that we've made has been about
risk-taking so I take more risk um I'd
be bolder
foreign
self to worry a bit less
seeing him learning how to be less
worried and and concerned I try to kind
of calculate everything estimate risks
and often think that oh it's not good
enough and I think like I would try to
keep that because it it pushes you to to
perform and put in a lot of effort and
work which obviously increases your
probability of success but like worry a
bit less because I think in the end
doing the right thing things come
together even if they don't sometimes
come when you want them to
tell my younger self that it's gonna be
okay and I know that's cliche but you
know I spend a lot of time worrying
about running out of time or making the
wrong decision but if I could tell my
younger self anything it would be look
eight nine times out of ten you end up
making the right decision and even if
you don't you always seem to figure it
out
being a first-time founder has just
really been such a learning process and
I keep saying the word learn and
learning and learned because that has
been the biggest takeaway for me so far
and there's always going to be bumps
along the way there's always going to be
mishaps and
launching a brand with it being a
hundred percent perfect and no hiccups
is not something that exists and I'm
such a perfectionist so I think that the
biggest lesson I'm learning is that I
have to let go of perfectionism and
allow myself to learn from the mistakes
that happen along the way because it
only helps your brand get better and
better when you learn from the mistakes
and move forward
[Music]
I would say
don't be afraid to take that risk
so often was I hesitant to say something
in an investor meeting or to pitch a
prospective client because I didn't
think we deserved their business or to
talk about Sparrow in a grandiose way to
borrowers because our product had
limited scope taking that risk is more
than just you know leaving the job and
starting a company it involves the daily
interactions that you have with all the
key stakeholders across the board
for myself two years ago three years ago
I wish I would have taken more risk but
calculated risk you're not gonna you
know throw yourself into something
without understanding what the potential
downfall might be but you take those
risks in spite of the outcome not
because of it
[Music]
I think I would tell my younger self get
ready and read a lot um I've learned so
much from other people's experiences
whether it's it's in books or whether
it's talking to people that I think I
would I would tell myself to do more of
that from the beginning so that I could
really accelerate my own learning one of
our values is maximize learning and I
think that's one way that I could have
done it better
[Music]
I would tell myself the day before I
started Protege to just go for it things
happen a lot more quickly than I would
have realized and with the power of of
our team we've been able to accomplish
so much in such a little time and I
think you know if I had any hesitation I
would have liked to
smush that into the ground
[Music]
listen to your gut and my gut knew this
was going to be a slam dunk and that's
why I took the risk and it's still
turning out and being fun and the other
one I guess have fun with it you know
it's going to be long hours it's going
to be stressful
but you're going to enjoy every minute
of it
foreign
[Music]